so for me by far one of the most
entertaining things that have come out
of these two films is a poster that's
able to be disturbing hilarious and
brilliant all at the same time try
getting that out of your mind before you
sleep tonight nymphomaniac volume 2 is
directed by lars von trier and star
charlotte gainsburg stellan skarsgård
and a whole bunch of people this movie
is the continuation from nymphomaniac
Volume one originally it was supposed to
be one film but Lars von Trier decided
to cut it into two because of its length
this is the continuation of Charlotte
Gainsbourg character recounting her past
life events to stellan skarsgård her
difficulties with sex addiction and
everything that comes along with it I
really enjoyed that first film I thought
it had a very clever way of telling
these events and I thought it was very
entertaining and even though it was a
little disturbing at times I thought
that the performances were fantastic I
thought it looked very good and I really
liked some of the different creative
ways he used to tell his story in this
film we pick up with this character and
she's incredibly bored with her sex life
she doesn't have anything in it that's
making it interesting for her so she
finds all these various ways to try to
liven it up and that makes this film a
lot more dark for the first half of this
film I was very interested in these
characters I was very very enticed by
her life and I wanted to see where she
was going to end up because you start to
care about her and the way she tells her
story is so interesting and a little bit
light-hearted but it gets really dark in
this film to the point where it starts
to get a little absurd and the
characters in this film start to do
things that completely betray who they
are and it turns into one of the lars
von trier endings that he's most famous
for he's very famous for making a film
that seems very okay this is the film
he's telling then it ends and he
switches everything on you and he has a
statement about humanity at the end of
this film that I completely disagree
with that I found was a total betrayal
of the characters he set up and this
film really dropped off the deep end in
a bad way this ending enraged me and I
think that was what he had in mind
because I don't walk into a movie
expecting a fantastic ending for
everything in fact when this movie
started I literally said to myself in my
head prepare for an ending that might
make you mad because that's generally
what he does and I prepared myself for
that but the thing is the way he ends
this film is really a giant middle
finger to the audience and he
on purpose I can tell because his entire
point with the way he ends it and I
won't spoil it for you if you haven't
seen it is to basically say that
humanity never changes that everyone's
evil and that there is no good in anyone
and no one will ever actually be a good
person without being selfish at the same
time and it really got under my skin but
it wasn't just because certain things
happened it seemed so absurd and so
unbelievably fake it was because the way
he set up all these characters was so
genuine and you really started to
believe these people were actually real
people because the performances were
also so genuine but the way he decided
to end his film completely betrayed
those characters and everyone did things
that they wouldn't have done and it
doesn't make sense it was just like I'm
gonna make a really shocking ending
that's gonna basically say hey you just
watched four hours of entertainment from
me and I don't care if you there's also
some very very very disturbing elements
to this movie sexually that didn't
really feel like they were necessary
because it began to border on fetishism
and the problem is that some of it
involves pedophilia and sexual abuse of
a violent nature and it wasn't really
depicting it in the way that it should
be I think and I am NOT an easily
offended person i watch a lot of stuff
and I'm not one of the guys that's going
to sit here and be like this movie was
bad and you should go to school and know
that I'm not even remotely like that I'm
just saying that when you put pedophilia
in a slightly positive light I don't
really agree with that I understand some
of the statements that he's making in
this movie and some of it was very
profound and some of it was very good it
was still very well acted but I think
that he lost a lot of the momentum that
he had from the first one in this film
and you can see how it was originally
supposed to be one film and then get
really dark and that's probably why I
enjoyed the first one more because it
actually felt like it had a whole group
of real genuine characters nevertheless
it still looked very good and it was
very well acted I'm gonna give a
nymphomaniac volume to a c-plus simply
because the last half of it just dropped
off the map and I don't even know what
happened it was just kind of a Lars von
Trier thing
hey don't care about you at all I'm just
going to make a movie I want to make I
would still suggest checking out these
two films simply because they are
filmmaking on a different level than
what most films are and that is
something to be commended if you guys
have seen these two films let me know we
thought below and as always thanks so
much for watching guys and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes